in the rain at the threshold of what
used to be a community center
a cleansing and desperately needed
release
[Music]
the joy a stark contrast from scenes of
a war ravaged nation
the mini concert a perk after a long day
of labor
more than three thousand residential
buildings were destroyed in the chernia
region which was under partial russian
occupation at the start of the invasion
you like don't believe that it's going
on you're just like okay so this is like
just a movie setting that was out here
it's not really real and then you
literally take this i don't know how you
call this brick
and you're like okay so i guess this is
not the movie setting can you imagine
that you build something for the whole
life
you collect money for that you like do a
lot of work here you do your own like
corner in this world and
you see
a lot of these volunteers say they felt
compelled to do something they couldn't
sit with idle hands so they're here
working on what used to be a two-story
house trying to clear this site for the
family who's also here working
father and son along with strangers from
around the ukraine but also poland and
the uk
i can't imagine that there is still so
much good left in the world they believe
their home was hit with fiery shrapnel
on march 5th
black pilopenko and his pregnant sister
and her husband were in the basement
when the house was hit and caught fire
now like many of their neighbors they're
worried about the winter
repair together a group that organized
this dance party cleanup says so far
they've helped 15 families in three
different villages
they hope to transition to rebuilding
parties
[Music]
their volunteers meanwhile have an
outlet for their tensions and fears
even just for a few beats
crystal comancing global news
near chernia ukraine